what's going on with the music [ __ ]
right now what do you got going on man
uh absolutely nothing nothing
no man no man I just uh I just dropped
the album called he got a gun
great name yeah
and um I did the whole album with my man
found him off over there the guy with
the mullet the producer yeah oh he's
here okay he did the whole album from
beginning to end so I had really lost
the love for hip-hop for a minute I
wasn't really [ __ ] with it so uh my
boy King Gordy introduced me to this guy
tracking Gordy yeah yep yep Detroit
Legend So van Nike and Harper
and uh this guy here he was just so pure
on hip-hop like I mean this I mean this
guy doesn't give a [ __ ] about nothing
but recording like so he had the like
typical old school basements dogs four
cats his girl four cats yeah damn this
girl cooking a meal and his kids jumping
around crazy just how to smell oh man
awful yeah that sounds like a [ __ ] up
house six dogs four cats food's getting
made and there's kids Chad's eating on
the counter all that [ __ ] you know I'm
not surprised
but it made it was an environment that I
needed man so you know he he brought
that whole you know what I'm saying that
old bizarre back the battle rap bizarre
wow before the crazy
sick rapist bizarre the crazy sick rape
is bizarre yeah yeah
so I'm proud of this album man you know
what I'm saying we uh
we just been I had to move in his
basement for two months
you lived in this basement with the cats
and the dogs yep damn shout out to
Gertie his dog his dog
and so while living there you finish the
album yeah nice yeah man it was a long
process too man because you know he
Records On Acid Pro
are you familiar are you kidding are you
Engineers familiar with that are you
kidding
serious yes
what year what can we help Cyrus before
he leaves
can we get him a crack
let's just get him let's get him a crack
for Pro Tools or something I haven't
heard Sony asses since high school we'll
get bro we'll get you a nice jump drive
we gotta get you right
okay I I still had to send it to your
boy on Pro Tools you're not gonna get
off that easy man
son wow salute to you man that's he's
been on it since like uh 73 74. some
since [ __ ] the internet started right
but it still got AOL
he's still got AOL AOL trial CDs okay
trial CDs but it gives the the rawness
of the album it gets the sound it gives
it a grit it gives us the hunger right
his house for like a bunch of tears that
went over there and we caught the bus
over there to do a song and [ __ ] nice